Hello everybody. My name is Markiplier,
And welcome back to Subnautica.
I'm still playing from the last session,
But I got even more names to put on the ro-
uh Ros?- laaaaaaaah
The lockers
*Screams*. ITS A LOCKER WITH AN L!
First up is erin_laneboy1 who says:
"Mark, Please make a bed,
helpful to sleep away the horrors of the night."
And while I appreciate that and
I will make a bed when I get back down to my base in the Grand Reef-
*Inhales*
Where I'm going...
We won't know day from night...
We won't know the horrors of the night...
From the horrors of the deep...
So it should be fun. I dunno. Maybe.
Anyway, next is kathytinda113 who said:
"Mark, they just added new cache
In The Lost River biome with a skull,
with teeth as big as your body."
I dunno, that seems pretty big, but
maybe I've seen bigger in my day, but
I'll keep a look out for that.
And I think,
That's probably where the Orange Artifact goes
if I had to guess.
But then last up is Dustinyuen1 who says:
"Mark, you can get resources off of the Reef Backs like silver.
(Like so Mark sees this please)"
And I, have never heard of such a theory,
But just outside this-
*Inhales*
Well they *cough* ran away from me.
Why'd you do that buddy-boo?
Why'd ya run away from me huh?
Oh, Oh now you're gonna-
Now you're gonna play HARD TO GET after
I'd been-
Pushin' ya away this whole time.
Well you come back here
If you've been squandering Silver from me.
I'mma be a little bit upset about that.
I might have to stab you a few times,
with Big Box Barry here.
And by stab, I mean ram OH so SENsually.
I'm calling to ya!
I'm calling to ya, baby.
Hey... How's it goin'?
I'm just gonna take a look at your...
Lovely backside...
Y-Y-Your rump-wOH you're big.
*Sounds of disgust*!
That's- That's really pulsating-
Ooh, hey. Okay.
Doooon't mind me.
Break barnacle?
What...?
Break barnacle? What de...
What?!?
Why did that break a-ooOOOooh.
Hey, okay.
I didn't-
Y-you had barnacles on you?!?
Where-
WHAT?!?
I had no idea about this...
Oh, I had n-
Oh ma-I have no-woah HEYHEYHEYHEY,
You wanna fight?
You wanna go brah? Huh, you wanna go?
Oh, oh you wanna go?
Huh, Huh? You wanna go?!?
OH! Take summa that! HO! HEY-Whatsthat?
Ohhhhh dead now oh aren't ya dead oh dead aren't ya!
-That's so weird.
I didn't know that was a thing that could happen-
Hey you come back here.
Aw, I had no idea!
Why didn't I know about this?!
Why didn't any of you guys tell me about this!
Doesn't seem to be working a 100% properly but-
I like it-
Aw, it's cool!
ALRIGHT ey, ey, ey, come on, come on. Back off of Big Box Barry y-It's o-yeah whatever.
Alright you know what? I'm going to scan you.
No, I'm not going to scan you I think I already scanned you at one point in my life. ALRIGHT, ENOUGH, ENOUGH!
I got a busy day ahead of me, you back off!
So I'm gonna go down...  (okay)
I'm gonna go way...
Way....
Way down...
And when I go down...
I don't know if I'm ever,
ever gonna come back up, so...
Fhoof- Here we gooo....
I'm just gonna go ahead and jump ahead to when I'm...
actually at my base. And I'll see you there...
Ahhhh....
Home sweet home.
S'gud to be back!
Good to be back-I wonder when Warp- (Warps in) oooohh RIGHT ON CUE!
Ooooh Warpy-Warpstashe
Oh, how good to see you.
Can ya plea-woooa....
Alright then...
Can you please go to hell?
An... And never bother me again-That'd be great... (Warps Out) Okay, Bye... thank you
That guy is oddly-
Od-oddly uh agreeable, today.
SO! What I need to do is: I need to gather the-ma-the materials neccesary b-
Ohh! Ugh! Elrgh!
EH I DON'T WANT THAT
URH I DON'T WANT THAT
Here- wait-
You here, CONMASTER
You take this. *Oorgf*
Um... I need to build the... Pressure Compensator Mk2 and Mk3
And to do that I need two Computer chips, which means
I need number 1: Silver, and number 2: Coral, which is where??
Kachiro, there you are. OK
So I need 2 Computer chips.
And....
Ugh, Quartz.
There we are, boink!
So shabooski!
alright
Now we got two computer chips
and with that
we should be able to make
the DEPTH MODULE that we need
to go AS DEEP
as we
POSSIBLY
can
"Welcome aboard, captain."
Which admittedly is pretty dang deep
and I believe
yeah, it's right here
so, if I take this
"Maximum depth reached."
I know
It's gonna be O.K.!
I-I'm not actually in it, it's fine
the pressure is O.K.
so if I take this...
and then I take
I belieeeve,
I need the plasteel ingot from here
yes, that one right there
and I NEEED
I need more than that...
Where di-ayuhh- where'd all my shit go?
WHERE'D ALL MY GODDAMN SHIT GO?!
(high pitch)WHERE'D DEY POOT ALL MAH PLASTEEL?!?!
DID I RUN OUT?
WHAAAAAAT?!
well that's a bunch'a
I thought I had MOAR!
Where's all my aluminum ox--
there's SOME of em'
-exasperated groan-
alright then... :(
well I gotta make plasteel now.
but it's FINE
cause I got a LOT of titanium
"an-ma-booooeeehhhdy"
Good thing I actually got more titanium
because otherwise I'd be up Shit Creek without a paddle!
SHUP DE WOOP!
SHUP DE WOOP
shup de woop
oookayy I've goooooooooooot
wuhn...one more
don't I?
I need ONE MORE plasteel ingot
this is TESTING THE LIMITS of all my resources here
I think I got more titanium inside
I don't--I got one more lithium on me,
So let's go back in
I could've sworn-
I COULD'VE SWORN
I did all of the titanium farming that I needed to
but
I still have extra, because
(BREAKS 4th WALL IN THIRD PERSON?!?!)
THAT'S WHAT PREPARATION DOES FOR YOU.
(YOU DONT KNOW WHATS GOOD FOR ME ME!)
it makes ya PREPARED
for shit like this
(YEA, RIGHT)
I'VE GOT
five plasteel ingots
and THAT- I b'lieve
is everything that I need
to be able to make
what I need to make in the
modification station
Which iyiaas...
Seamoth upgrade?
YEP!
NUMBER ONE!
or number TWO, rather
shabuski
and then
STRAIGHT ONTO NUMBER THREE!
HEEEEEELL YEAH!
All right.
We've finally done it!
I set it to do this about
three episodes ago
and we finally did it
we got enough to be able ta' make
THIS.
Pressure compensator.
which, even in the Seamoth,
is pretty admirable
But not enough to get too far down.
but
at least
AT. LEAST!
now my Seamoth
can do some exploration
on its own
if I wanted to do that,
up to 900 meters.
But that's not why I need this.
(overlapping notification voices/
COMPUTER TURNING INTO H.A.L.)
SO.
What I'll eventually have to do
is just make another, uh,
pressure compensator for
Bumble Butt if I wanted to
take him out
but for now, I
can actually SWITCH
between the two of em'.
And that'll be...
AUOOOOGHHHH! >:(
*dies a little bit inside*
WHY WERE YOU THERE?!?!
WHY IN THAT ONE!!
WHY WAS
WHY WA
WHY WERE YOU IN THAT ONE
HUH
YOUWANA
UUUUUUUUUUUUUHHHHH
You are playing games with me, HUH?
OOOOO You're
*Markimooing* *sexy face*
MMMM OKAY, ALRIGHT
I see what you're doing- okay, I see.
Alright-
Alright, You know what? That's okay
I didn't NEED it
I didn't NEED IT
Whatever.
It's. fine.
Cool.
Great.
Love ya BUNCHES >:(
Oh God! Okay
Fine then.
The game's gonna be a bit of a Sassy Sue~
*All systems online*
I'll be okay
I'll- I'll get by
Let me just eat some fruit to calm my nerves-
And then, It's time to start the adventure.
The adventure that you and I have been waiting for and th..
*Swallows Burp*
I've been dreading for a while now
Let me just pop the power cells out.
Okay! We are almost at full power. Pop these bad boys back in there...
Babudoom Babudoom
And Babuzooom
And then put one away
OKAY!
ALRIGHT
*INHALE*
Okay!
*wrong one*
That's not what i'm looking for
Alright! OKAY!
*flexes* ERGH
Okay! (more groans)
Okay, alriiiiiiight
BLULULULU alriiiight
OKAY
Alright
Cool
Cool, Okay
Here we go!
We are off on our journey down into the depths of hell.
And I don't even know if I can fit in there-
(Too tight? or is she just Ghosting you)
Through this hole in the ground but... Gonna try!
Gonna try
(No Comment on that one >_>)
I'm actually going go down there
Great
Okay good
Can I navigate with this
*Spooky noises*
Whoa, hey that's close
Whoa.
Dats spooky
(copy cat)
alright then
Here we go!
Wooah~ Alright, I think the entrance is around ere-
Eyup I think that might be it right there...
Ooh I'm not gonna fit through THAT hole
but I COULD fit through a different one, so...
anywhe- OH right there that's that'd be it... that'd be a lot better
OH, navigating this thing is...
NOOOOOOT fun :(
alright I just gotta circle around and do this again...
I wanna reiterate that this is a bad idea
trying to navigate my bubblebutt in here
OH, I'm just asking for trouble, aren't I?
I'm just asking for...
a headache, and me screaming in rage. that's whada- that's what I'm asking for
Here we go. okay. I think I made it in
wooOOoo we're close, we're close. Woooaahhh, we're too close to THAT
okay thank you, sorry, pardon me. PARDON me. I'M IN!!
okay. smooth as butter
SMOOTH as a baby's bottom
alright... HEY! you guys aren't so scary now that i'm bigger than YOU, HUUH?!?!
EAAAGH!
YEAH THat's what I-  ahh don't mind me
Don't mi- Excuse my girth
pardon me
pardon my GIRTH. pardon me, pardon me
I think maybe THAT way looks like it goes down. that's nice
I like down... down's good
Oh, hello. alright..
ah, yes. AH. Good. oh yes okay..
yah no yah. I wish I was anywhere but here
that goes back UP, so not going that way
that looks down- *sea creature noises* HEEYYY FUCKING FUCKING FUCKING FUCK
what was THAT?!
What was that?
the  ffff-uck was that?
is that the crabsquid?
think that might be the crabbysquiddo
s'good thing that they stopped it from being just-
just bang into something and get a hole in your ship
plasteel aint too bad at uh.. ahha woah heyyy
you wanna get rammed? you wanna get rammed, buddy?
fricking weirdo..
*oceanlife noises* yeesh
good thing that doesn't seem to do anything to me.
alright, going down, going down
ay ay ay- okay is that- waAAah fuck off with you
it's hard enough to navigate without you screaming in my ear
alright, okay, alright, woAh
yeee... okay.
Ahhhhhhh..... ay ay ay
okay i'm seeing floor down there
uhhh... oh, that looks deep. okay...
just try this way first i guess
I think it was just behind me, but I-I I'm  I just I have to like go the long way
oh, no wait actually that is-
that's nice and deep. that's pretty deep. I may have found it
okay I think I got it
this seems pretty down, deep, dark, and deepy
woah that's- d'oh hey okay alright then. you got places to be, I understand. busy crab
alright we've done it- eeeughhheeeugghhhh I don't like this
alright let me get out of this camera view
OH I can't see ANYTHING
oh this is not helpful at all- there we go, okay, now I can see something
okay
WOO! gonna saaave.. eurblblblblb
lemme go down in here- that is definately the start of the lost river
goody goody gumdrops I'm glad I'm here
*NOPE NOPE NOPE NOPE NOPE*
EEEAAAUGHHHH
alright. back into this. I've been here before, I can do this again
and it's not that scary it's not that bad I got this under c- lock and key
I think. we shall see~
ah it's so weird
piloting big box barry because things look so much different when you're up above 'em, and when you're down on the ground
with uhh- with Mr. Fister
things look just vastly different and-
it's not too comforting being up here and seeing it all from this scale, but-
you never know. we shall see, we shall see
Aaaaahhhhhhhhh, hello. HELLO! someone told me about teeth as large as my body...
and somehow that was the entrance to some sort of- precurser cache
are you telling me that you...
you there, are some sort of precurser... entrance?
is that what you're telling me? Or is there another
is there another one of you... 'round here that I should know about?
'cause if there is, I...
ahhh I don't think I wanna know about it. Yeah you don't look like you got an entrance to nothin' in you~
then again, those teeth aren't exactly as big as my body
it might be close, but maybe not as big
so let's see what else we got in store over here- I need to get farther down
and I need to see what's going on with that tree.
I seem to be stuck on something- WHAT AM I STUCK ON? I've got things to see and places to be!
so somewhere down here -maybe all the way in the inactive lava zone. maybe not here
but somewhere, down here there are fish that will attatch onto my Big Box Barry
and then suck the power away from him.
Now, if I was wearing- if I had my seamoth, it has like a- I can make an electricity defense system
a perimeter defense system, but I don't think I can do that for my cyclops
So I'm just gonna have to beat em off with a knife
I think that's what I've been told, so..
that's exactly what I'm gonna do
oh this is bizarre- this is bizarre- this is- I mean I know I've seen this before,
but seeing it from this angle is definitely different
ooooh
yeesh *loud noise* *inhale from spooked mark*
ssooOOOORRYYYyyyy nyeh.. alright...
Ok so, I think NOW would be a good point
or maybe on this plateu over here
would be a good point to pop out Mr. Fister and then swap
the uh
pressure compensator in so then I can go even farther- I mean I
can go to 1500 meters with- Big Box Barry
and I'm gonna keep going with it, but I need to pop that in to Mr. Fister before we do that
so that he doesn't die.
Oh there it is!
That's what I've been waiting for- I caught a glimpse of it a LONG time ago, and now
Finally!
Finally getting back here!
So lets SAVE and we've got FOOD, we've got WATER, we've got materials!
We've got saved game, we've got all this shit- and uh- YEAH, yeah, yeah, yeah. We're do- uh we are doin it, we are doing this!
*Hushed* We're doing this
So we're going to pop into the PRAWN, uh- save first, because you know I don't wanna- uh
get caught with my PANTS DOWN, and my save file not... nice.
upgrade the- access the upgrades, *ocean noise* euh I don't like that. Pressure compensator, there we go!
Ok!
1700 meters, so now my prawn suit can go as deep as it possibly could go!
"Welcome aboard captian" -Cyclops
but I'm still gonna go forward in my cyclops because I'm scared.
*Sucking in air through teeth*
here we go! Lets see what this, brain tree is all about.
Cause i- if I'm not mistaken this looks like something of significance
and I don't know... if it is,
I don't know what that means, but it's here.
And it looks weird! Because that looks like a brain
or an egg! :)
I'm not sure which would be worse if this- woah hey!
Hi friends! :)
I'm not sure which would be worse at this point, but- oh hey!
friends?! :/
.... ..  ...  . .
but that's, bizzare.
That is... super weird!
Let me get a good at ya! Oh, what is that?!
AWH
That is like an egg!
That looks a hundred percent like an egg
I mean not that I am an EGGSpert on eggs or anything, but its kind of a translucent nature that those, those
weird, fish are- if you can even call those fish or maybe manta rays, like that
oh don't cha come near me buddy boo <3 Don't cha come near me.
but, that looks a hundred percent like an egg.
But, I'm gonna pop outta here! I'm not gonna move on from it just yet. I wan- I wanna get a close look at this.
But that might be my undoing, so I'm gonna save first.
*Weird noise, VERY UNEASY FACE*
...I...
I don't know if I appreciate the WHISPERING!
WOAH
Where are the othe- woah!
Where the other worldly glow
Can I scan this thing? The frick is that?!
*Deep sea noise* NUEH
*Sea creature noise*
WHOAAH, ok!
I think I've heard these before but
man, being up-
Oh! I can scan it- Giant cove tree!
What the hell?
Woah!!
Alien lifeforms: Giant Cove Tree
That looks a hundred percent like an egg! Can I like get a sample of it?
No?
Nuh? Ok.
I'm probably just ANGERING them by stricking their god! Ok, I'm going to get back to the ship an try to analyze this data I just scanned
Eee!
Ok! Back in the ship for safety- ok. What do we got? Flaura:
Giant Cove Tree:
WOW! "This vast tree supports a THRIVING local - uh-  ecosystem"
"FURTHER DATA UNAVAILABLE AT THIS TIME."
GREAT!
Thanks for that!
That helps!
I'm glad about that!
FURTHER DATA UNAVAILABLE. Good!
Good to know! >:(
So the developers just haven't put the data in there yet, but
there's a little more that we can explore here. I'm not done yet!
Getting close to the end of the episode here but I'm not done. I want to press forward
Cause this landmark area is like the limiter. For where you can go WITHOUT the right materials.
And right now I've GOT the right materials, and a lot of em. But we're not- oh, we are.
we are entering...
I think!
a volcanically active area if I'm not mistaken. WERRRR
I just announced my pressence for everybody here. And why are all those thing congregating right there??
They must have something do- to do in connections with that thing! Oh what is that?
OOoo
Kay, maybe not the lava zone just yet but
something else. oh, IS THAT SILVER?!! Oh thats probably nickel, ok. I- I'm not gonna be too mad about that uh
oh no. Ok, this definetly looks like lava walls! God it's so crazy to think about how this wasn't all like this just a little bit ago.
Or not even a little bit ago, but like, half a year ago. This all wasn't here. I gotta, I think I gotta navigate manually now. But this all wasn't here and
*SPOOKY WHISPERING noise* Eeee
AGAIN! with the whisperingg I..I.. don't apprecieate that! >:(
I mean I know..... I know I'm probably loosing sanity as I'm down here
but, ehh still don't appreciate that!
Not my favourite thing in the world. WOAH! WOAH...
HOAh, Ok! I've officially entered the lava zone! Oh boy!
Oh, HEY! What are you? Are you the energy leecher? Are you the energy leech?? Yeah, Yeah, YOU STAY AWAY!
Stay away from my SHIP! Stay away from me and my son!
Woah!
Hoah OK.
Oh boy! Oh boy, Oh boy, Oh boy, OH BOY!
We're at a 1000 meters!
Going down!
Oooo...
There are some weird materials here
that I haven't seen before.
I think that might be sulfur right there so
Let me- let me hop out real quick and grab those
Before anything kills me.
I'mma hop out, grab those-
It might be hot down here, I did not make-
Forgot to make the heat resistant suit.
That's- that's something I definitely did do. (Sarcasm)
Damnit, I'm an asshole
maybe I be, I might be able to make while I'm- Euh!
I've never heard this music before- EH! Ok I'm beggining to think that's actually a thing. Hey c'mon now!
I've got a knife, its hardened by diamonds, slice you up buddy boo!
If you're the energy leeches I ain't gonna play nice! Yeah, you stay away from my ship, ok maybe you aren't the leeches but I still don't like you!
uh, getting a little- UGH YOU ARE!! You are the energy leech, aren't you! I'm getting you off of my ship! You sack of ass!
You get off, geh- geh- geh- HEY! What are you doing? Yeah! Geh- GET OFF! Thats right, GET OFF! Off, Off, OFF, OFF! Off, come scan ya.
Lava Larve, are they everywhere on my ship? If they are I'm going to be so screwed. I think that means I shouldn't stay in one place for long.
Hopefully they stick only to the front so that you can see them,
cause that'd be pretty-
Pretty unfortunate, if they if they don't-
Fauna, Scavengers, uh- Lava Larvae.
"A grub-like species which
appears to lack a sense of sight and smell,
but is able to sense and drain thermal energy in the environment."
"1.Underside Suction Cup: Capable of attaching to
smooth surfaces and generating high pressure suction."
*Inhales*
"2.Torzo: Scales t' protect from 'xtreme adventures-
Uh- temperatures,
lacks traditional digestive system."
[Mark still reading v.v] "
-Attracts to energy sources of all kinds,
-Draws thermal energy from it's prey to survive,"
"Avoid deploying powered vehicles in it's vicinity."
WELP, TOO LATE FOR THAT.
But further down...
We shall go.
I don't know what that is,
I've never seen that material before and
I kinda wanna also see what kinda-
Materials in the lava rocks. WhAT is that?
I don't know what that is.
It's definitely not Diamond.
I'm gonna bring Mr. Fister out,
And try to see what's up.
Alright, what have we got 'ere.
Give me YOUU.
What are you- Woah..
(Mechanical robot/Drilling sounds)
Aaaalright?
It dosen't look like anything I've seen before,
But maybe I'm mistaken.
Mm where d'it go?
[Mysterious rock floats away]
Well gosh darnit.
Lost that.
(More drilling)
Am I crazy?
Is it not doing anything or...
What's goin' on.
Is it just, eroding to nothing-ness? Is it-
(Even more drilling)
It seems to just be eroding into nothing-ness.
So what is it?
I'll just scan it first.
(After drilling into it twice)
*Facepalm*
Wait- It's nothing!
It literally is nothing.
Why's it here?
It looks very important.
-t's decoration, I guess but-
Maybe a future material that I'm not-
Ready for yet, I guess...
I feel naked even in my Exosuit here.
LEMME IN.
LEMME IN BIG BOY.
LEMME IN. Whooah..
Lemme go a little farther.
Jus' takin' it too slowly cuz I'm a coward...
Hooah. We gotta see what's over there.
WoAh I am stuck on something.
What am I stuck on- There we go.
Alright, little more, little more, little moar, come on.
Turn, Turn, TURN. YOU BIG BOIII.
Come on, that way. Alright.
They have really-
Really changed this area.
A lot.
(Background noises)
It's craayzy.
Cause last time I went 'ere,
There was a lot of lava,
Aaand, there was a lot of zone,
But not a lot, else.
So, it's just- woofh.
Fascinating to see-
How much different it is now-
Then it was, just-
Half a year ago.
It's hard to tell which way is more down but
it's just like- I guess I just follow the lava.
(More underwater background noises)
It's all I really need to know I (mumbles) jus' suppose.
How far are we down?
We'r- we're almost at 1200m down,
so not the FARTHEST that we could go,
But I think we're about to broach the opening-
Of the main area of the Lava Zone.
Aw man I really can't see anything-
Yeesh.
Okay, little farther down-
Oh, maybe not too far down.
Oh is that a Lava WATERFA-AWw Nice!
I like that!
Good feature!
Looks good!-
Looks... terrifying.
Yeesh.
Ohhh, mmm-
MAWMA.
Oh Mama.
Kay- can I-can I go down there?
Do I wanna go down there?
Ooh, I don't know if I WANNA go down there, but-
Seems like maybe that's the place that I SHOULD go.
I'm- that's probably ONE place I could go and
Mr. Fister would be able to go down there.
I jus' don't know if I wanna down jus' yet.
Oh Wait- Nope. That's a hole that I could probably fit in
GREAT. Okay.
IIIIhhh'm not gonna go there just yet.
I'm not feelin' that brave enough.
I'M A BIG BRAVE BOY, don't get me wrong,
but I'm just not feelin' brave enough to go down there
Juuuust yet.
So, we're gonna see about that.
But what I DON'T know, is
someone said there was a Research Base-
Somewhere, in The Lost River.
So maybe I missed a turn and maybe-
*Inhales*
Maybe I need to go back and get that. But-
I jus' kinda wanna get-
Into The Unknown.
And that is definitely- Aoh no good-
Thank you-
That's NOT definitely-
Down into the deep, dark abyss.
Euuwh. Oh- That's- new.
What are you??
Ooooahh- What are YOU?
You're new.
What ARE you??
"Caution. Mild dehydration detected."
Euuh.
Ya I'll get to that in a second-
Ooh. Is that- Is that like
The Lava Castle or somethin?
WOAah- It's a Lava SPIRE,
That's for sure.
Oah- And then some new creature here.
Okay.
So I haven't run into the DRAGON yet
Which has been... Kinda my Fear
Up until this point, but uh-
Maybe that's for the best.
Maybe uh-
Maybe I should just keep that out of there. But-
We are literally in the middle of the inactive Lava Zone and
It's looking a lot more active than it once did. So..
I'mma, unfortunately end the episode here. D:
But in the next one,
We're gonna explore this place fully.
And deeply.
And look for those-
[Outro music starts] Pre-cursor Caches, and
Look for the place to put this
Orange-
Artifact that I have in my inven-mtory
Right now because apparently-
*Inhales*
The only place to put it is there.
We've got a lot more to explore- Hi.
So, Thank you everybody so much for watching,
And as always, I will see you,
In the next video.
Ba-Bye!
[Outro Music]
potato salad
SCHWOOPDY-Z